welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
we're breaking down Spider-Man across
the spider-verse the movie has a hell of
a lot going on with it and it ends by
setting up the events of its sequel
called beyond the spider verse
throughout this video we're gonna be
going over what happens in it some of
those big Easter eggs and also talking
about everything we know about what's
coming in that third film
[Music]
and then I look
uh let me guess he died
the film has a major Cliffhanger and we
end with Miles Morales traveling to
Earth 42. this is because the spider
that originally bit him was from that
Dimension and this injected him with its
DNA therefore when he attempted to
return to his home through using the
spider Society machine it sent him back
to the origin world of the spider
instead this is kind of how the end of
the film plays out but before we do a
deep dive on it I feel like we have to
talk about what got us to that point
think you are really
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
the film is Loosely and I say Loosely
Loosely Loosely based on the
spider-verse and spider getting graphic
novels there's a big Omnibus collecting
all the stories that was recently
released with the original part of this
being published in 2014 just before this
in the main Spider-Man story Peter
Parker had actually been tricked by Dr
Octopus to swap bodies with him which
led to be ending up in Doc's frail and
failing figure dying before he could
reverse the process we watch izak became
the quote-unquote superior Spider-Man
and I seldom beats our brain was a
fragment of his Consciousness which
acted somewhat like a ghost that looked
over what Arc was up to this and by just
being Spider-Man it slowly changed stock
himself and he became a better man which
kinda takes us into the edge of the
spider-verse story now why am I telling
you all of this well that's because
superior Spider-Man was pulled into 2099
and we watches lots of different
versions of the characters all United a
lot of which appear in this movie The
Spider Gwen Miguel O'Hara Spider-Woman
spider Punk spider cop spider a ham
superior Spider-Man lots of different
ones and a hell of a lot more we have we
actually have a full breakdown going
over all the different Spider-Man in the
film if you want to check that out but
I'll be here all day going over them if
we just stick to that anyway the film
itself starts off with Gwen and her own
universe trying to be a spider protector
of the city like all spider people she's
trying to balance her heroism alongside
her life but this brings everything in a
conflict with this universe as Peter the
first film showed that he was this
universe's lizard but we get the
backstory of it all filled in here the
pair Were Meant to attend a prom just
like Peter and homecoming but he
transformed into the lizard whereas
Peter got Liz odd now turns out he'd
expect sorry about that it turns out
he'd experiment on himself in order to
try and live up to her and after Gwen
drops scaffolding on him he turns back
into his human form he reveals
harinukuen with Spider Woman the whole
time and at this point Captain Stacy
comes in whose death was of course a
major event too that happened in Amazing
Spider-Man 88 and it actually inspired
what we see playing out here Stacy was
crushed by Falling Rubble attempting to
save a child during a battle between Doc
Ock and Spider-Man instructed Peter to
look after his daughter he of course
ended up breaking that promise like he
broke her neck
now we of course know from the first
spider-verse film exactly what happened
to him but his death summing a captain
Stacy blames Spider Woman for he started
hunting his daughter unaware of who she
was but we learn at the beginning of the
film that he eventually found this out
this plays into the ending of the film
which we'll talk about more as we get
further into the video but it's a very
important thing that we have to bring up
here his death is of course a major
event in the comics and like Uncle Ben
he's one of those characters that needs
to die to Define that universe's spider
person she ends a famous reality and we
get a gap of a couple of months from
this point where she clearly learns
about her father's death She's Come to
accept it because she knows that's the
cost of being a hero and she hasn't
visited Miles because she's keeping that
from him either way death is a big theme
in the film with it also being cements
tied in very closely with Miles Gwen is
tasked with tracking down the spot who
we learn is on miles's earth going
against protocol she ends up hanging out
with Miles which is being said to be a
big No-No miles is an anomaly and
hanging out with him could have a knock
on effect it's possible this could end
up causing an incursion down the line
which is a topic I want to discuss in
detail during an upcoming video on the
film boil down to its most Basics though
hopping through the Multiverse can cause
a number of devastating issues and we
even get a reference to how Spider-Man
and the MCU caused a ton of crap don't
even get me started on Doctor Strange
and a little nerd back on earth 1999.99
now Miguel meets grenellion and he too
talks about how the events of the first
spider-verse film have led to lots of
villains hopping across realities this
includes a vulture who makes a brief
appearance in the film and he comes from
a Renaissance painting sort world the
spider Society is trying to stop the
Multiverse from being messed up as this
can lead to the destruction of reality
as for the spot we have some major
different references and similarities
compared to what we get in the source
material both Adam working for Kingpin
and we learned in the film that he was
actually the character who got hit with
the bagel at the facility turns out he
was there at the super collider too and
it's such a cool way to tie this film in
with the previous one now in the comics
Jonathan on was tasked with studying the
cloak as a way to copy his powers in
case you don't know the cloaks basically
someone who possesses the powers of
being a living portal and he can access
something called the dark force
Dimension controlling it with his cloak
he has the ability to transport people
to and from there that's what Jonathan
was studying and his surname's also a
pun for the word spot on which being an
Englishman I actually really appreciate
now as with most experiments in the
Marvel Universe things went awry and the
spot was sucked into a portal which he
initially thought was the cloaks one
however this was a different type of
Dimension and it was made of Half Light
and half Darkness surrounded by portals
Jonathan swam through the dimension
which is when he managed to make it back
back to the portal that he just come
through realizing that the portals had
now stuck to his skin he had the ability
to warp wherever he wanted that's when
he started using his powers for his own
selfish reasons and it's sort of like
when Peter became a wrestler which I'll
never forget mate you got you got your
bloody Uncle killed you son of a
see you chump now they discovered
something similar in the film with Gwen
scanning the spot to room to see him
experimenting away now the spot in the
film ends up traversing through the
Multiverse in order to build up his
powers so that he can become Godlike
journeying to every alchemax in every
reality that has one he uses the super
collider to improve his powers so that
he can become someone who controls the
entire Multiverse I think or he just
wants revenge now if that first point is
true then we've of course seen something
similar in Kang and there was still
early days in the MCU he's likely gonna
have a similar goal now he who remains
is the end game of those who control all
realities and it's possible that we'll
end up with some teasers towards him in
beyond the spider verse if they decide
to lean more in with the MCU which with
away stuff with Jonathan Mages is going
uh I might just want to stick to Mobius
anyway we discover that Miles shouldn't
really be because the spider that bit
him was actually a spider from an
alternate universe every kid of the
first film we can catch it glitching out
and there's also the number 42 on its
back which denotes the universe it comes
from the number 42 popped up several
times in that film and it was constantly
there in scenes to give little hints
towards this also it's been said this
was chosen because it's the number
Jackie Robinson wore who was the first
black baseball player in the NBL I do
remember reading that at the time but
every time I brought it up someone said
it's wrong but yeah it's out there so I
thought I'd talk about it also 42 it's
the answer everything which if you've
read Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
you know that's a fact anyway back to
the point miles shouldn't exist and the
spot messing with the Multiverse has
very much led to his creation upon
following Gwen to where his next Target
is we arrive in the world of Spider-Man
India in the comics pavita papakar's
family ditch life and their Village to
move to Mumbai after he gained a
scholarship at a school this is of
course similar miles in the first movie
and the kids there made fun of him
because of his poorer upbringing also
they changed things up with the location
and simply turned Mumbai into mumbatin
which is a nice little touch he
encountered an ancient Yogi who gave him
those spider powers but he initially
just used them for his own gain ignoring
someone being attacked by muggers he
returned to the scene to find that his
uncle had left in to stop them and that
he'd been critically injured during this
from this point onwards he decides to
use his abilities for good dany's
protected when baton ever since this
spot ends up using the collider in his
universe and during this miles ends up
seeing a vision in which he promises to
take everything away from him the spot
has a vendetta against Miles because of
the first film and also due to him
making fun of him during their early
encounter this is when miles sees a
vision of his father dying which we come
to learn is known as his Canon moment
every Spider-Man origin story is mod
with tragedy in the miles's uncle Aaron
died in the first film the universe
demands more blood his dad is due to
become a police officer within 48 hours
and this is the event in which he will
diet now we see the effect with what
could happen if miles was to change
anything as he saved some unbat an
equivalent to Captain Stacy which causes
a Quantum collapse thus in order for the
universe to stay stable miles has to go
and let his father die now if you played
the first Spider-Man PS4 game then
you'll know a similar thing happen in
that and during a section you got to
play as miles before his dear old dad
was killed this is supposed to be a
defining moment in the character's life
but marvelous isn't willing to let it
happen or as the others have just
accepted it this is of course seen in
Gwen and also Miguel who gets a slightly
different origin story to what he had in
the comics in those he didn't really
have a quote-unquote Uncle Ben moment
but here they've gone on to switch
things up Miguel wanted a family unless
he traveled to Universe where a variant
of him had died and left them on their
own however in stopping a Canon event it
destroyed the entire universe and now
this truth has caused him to be angry
and bitter at the world or worlds now
rather than working like an incursion an
extreme alteration has disastrous
effects which he's now trying to stop
from happening in every reality miles is
the one who wants to change things
whereas he wants things to just stay the
same going back to the MCU again this
entire organization is run like the TVA
with its sort of being a dictatorship
that storms out any variants in
anomalies known as Nexus events in the
grand scheme of things this can
ultimately lead to multiversal Wars
incursions and so on this is why he
didn't want Gwen saying miles as it had
the potential to lead to trillions of
lives being lost and the comics Miguel
O'Hara comes from the futuristic city of
Nueva York which is where he got a job
working for the alcamex corporation
working as a scientist for them he was
pressured into running an experiment on
himself which would imprint genetic
codes onto humans his DNA was spliced
with out of a spider and it gave the
powers that we see him having here the
film is packed with lots of different
cameo videos from across the
spider-verse at one point we see the
Lego Universe and here we get JK Simmons
voicing Jay Jonah Jameson J Jonah pops
up at several points in the film with
his voice-periding Spider-Man depending
on what Universe we're in how about come
the end we hear him talking about the
Sinister Six cartel due to that Universe
not having its own Spider-Man there's
also Mrs Chen from the Venom verse who
appears at one point as well Captain
Stacy's death from The Amazing
Spider-Man Shone which is tied directly
to Andrew Garfield's vision and the Remy
verse Uncle Ben death scene can be
spotted on a monitor 2. at this point in
the movie Mars is given a tour of the
hauling Souls of villain instead of hop
from one Universe to another he can
catch the PS4 Spider-Man here and also
the little green Atari version of the
Green Goblin amongst the cells we can
catch Donald Glover and he's appearing
as a live-action Prowler this is one of
the best Easter eggs in the entire
Marvel universe as Donald was originally
the inspiration for Miles back when
Amazing Spider-Man was being made Glover
wore Spider-Man costume him in the
community episode called anthropology
101 Ryan Michael Bender saw this and he
decided to create miles who ended up
appearing in the Ultimate Universe
Glover went on to voice Miles Morales
and the Ultimate Spider-Man cartoon
which is a great way to bring everything
full circle unfortunately Glover got too
old to play miles in live action but
they did a nice little nod to him in
Spider-Man homecoming cursed his uncle
Aaron Peter had a couple of run-ins with
the character and even talked about his
little nephew miles cut it into the
spider-verse and we had a moment in
Uncle Aaron's apartment which is when we
saw the episode of community on the TV
this had him in the costume and we had
someone who was secretly the prowler
watching an actor who'd played the
prowler that had inspired the creation
of his nephew by wearing a Spider-Man
costume in the show that they had on TV
in this scene add to this my mind blown
now they of course have pulled them
across here for this amazing Easter egg
but I don't even explain all that and
how deep the layers go with this added
on top however it builds on so many cool
bit of trivia and it's easily one of my
favorite parts of the film now someone
who becomes a big Ally to miles in the
movie is my boy spider Punk he's all
about rebelling against the machine not
conforming to anything and I loved
hearing his constant little comments
voiced by Daniel caluier he first
debuted back in The Amazing Spider-Man
10 and this came from 2015. the
character hails from Earth 1-8 and
originally he was riffing on spider UK
in the books we discovered that he was a
homeless teenager named Hobart Brown who
was transformed due to some Oscorp toxic
waste known as a rocker he pretty much
always carries a guitar with him and
he's even used this to beat up Norman
Osborne he gave Smiles a tip on how to
escape by using his electrical Venom
Powers which aren't to be confused with
the character Venom after that he ends
up quitting the spider team and amongst
them we also get to meet some others
again going through them all in another
video but the main ones to focus on a
Spider Woman and the Scarlet Spider
israe's version of the character is
loosely based on the Jessica Drew
version who actually appears throughout
several parts of the film she's a
variant of her and she's slowly been
becoming a bigger character in the
Marvel Universe introduced in 1978 she
was just created because Stanley was
worried that another comic book company
would make their own character called
Spider-Woman originally Drew was only
supposed to be in a Marvel Spotlight but
she was so popular at the time that they
decided to use her and more given a
series with her Marv Wolfman went over
her backstory and he changed things up
from what had been established
Spider-Woman was meant to be a spider
that transformed into a woman but this
is pretty stupid so the retcon dead so
these were just memories implanted by
Hydra after several origin redo's and
retcons we've ended up with the current
one in the comics whose mother was hit
by a radiation beam when she was
pregnant containing multiple spider
genes these gave her her powers and she
became one of the most prominent
characters in the Marvel Universe a
Scarlet Spider has kind of been
ostracized but he originates from the
clone saga that dominated the 90s during
their time published shares replacing
the main Heroes over the versions and
just in the same way that Batman was
replaced by Jean-Paul Valley Peter
Parker was pushed out too the clone saga
right it went on forever and ever and
ever and ever and it was such a slug to
get through at the time due to how long
they dragged it out for it's going to
hit some reverence over the last couple
of years but yeah if you're planning on
reading it just stick to the essential
titles hit a point where you could tell
they didn't know how they were going to
end it and they just kept dropping
Fuller comic after fella comic after
filler coming and the clown was actually
created by the Jackal and this was done
by using Peter's DNA when the Jackal was
killed back in the 1970s it was thought
that doppelganger died with him however
somehow in the 90s he returned realizing
that he was a clone he decided to live
in Exile and this was so he didn't
interfere with the main Peter Parker
using his uncle's first name and
antmate's maiden name he was inspired to
become his own person and he settled on
the name Ben Reilly sort of worked like
a Drifter moving from town to town
helping people and this allowed him to
keep a low profile his spider sensated
several police investigations and he
fell in love with a woman named Janine
who was two on the Run being racked with
Guild she ended her own life and then
Ben became a janitor at a Poland high
school he saved a woman from some home
Invaders and was once more in spite to
use his great powers to take on great
responsibilities as Uncle Ben says with
great responsibility comes great rice
and he continued living life like this
until he went back to New York
confronting Peter he worked alongside
Spider-Man as the Scarlet Spider and
eventually became the main one after it
seemed clear Peter didn't want to do it
anymore now one of the big twists in the
comic was that Peter was thought to be
the Clone and that Ben was actually
supposed to be the original it drove
Peter almost insane and though they kept
their names he ended up quitting of
course this was eventually all revealed
to be untrue and Peter Parker took the
role back on as the main one but there
was a time where Ben was your main
Spider-Man though he wasn't that loved
at the time by the majority I'd say the
guy is definitely built a cult following
and his amazing costume design looks so
cool in the film also whenever I say
like this character wasn't that popular
back then you'll always get someone like
yeah they were mate yeah they were but
why was he changed back then why was he
changed back you kid no I'm not
lying about the 90s mate that's the one
thing I won't lie about come on anyway
that takes us into the final few scenes
in which we watches the spider Society
try to track down miles whilst miles
tries to get back to his dad returning
to an earth that looks like his he finds
his mother and confesses everything but
it's not all that it seems his mom has
no idea who Spider-Man is and his uncle
Aaron is still alive this is actually
Earth 42 which is where the original
Spider came from and due to its absence
things have changed drastically Aaron is
still alive and well and this is due to
the Kingpin not killing him because he
never needed to due to Spider-Man not
being there how about the event that
caused Jefferson's death Still Remains
and this is sent miles off on a
completely different path he's now the
prowler of this universe a complete
badass whilst his uncle Aaron Works
alongside him beaten and tied up we end
with Miles captured and he's saying
confronted by Prowler miles his interest
is peaked by the fact his father's still
alive and he learns that he's out there
layers somewhere in the Multiverse
though we don't exactly learn what he
wants to know about him I think it could
hint to what his end goal is personally
I think that he might just want to
travel out of that reality and take
miles's place so he can be with a family
he never had the whole movie is kind
about miles realizing just how good his
family is and that he should embrace
them instead of hiding away who he is
this is why he confesses to his mother
at the end of the film but it's
obviously a different one that he's
doing it too also nice little touch but
miles pronounces his name with more of
an espanol twang to it which is likely
due to his mother being there whilst his
father isn't I hope I don't get canceled
for that now I think he misses the
dynamic though and we'll do whatever he
can to see him this is very similar to
The Kingpin in that first spider-verse
film he was seeking out a version of his
family from another reality and Miguel
of course followed a similar sort of
motif both had disastrous effects with
this clearly being a theme that the
villains follow in the film a thing with
it being something that we've seen both
of the antagonists that this will also
to be something that's carried across
the problem miles in that next movie I
know Miguel isn't someone who's a now
and out villain but when we look at the
movie he's definitely the person who's
paying out as the guy that Miles has to
overcome after watching an entire
universe being destroyed he's realized
this isn't the way to live and instead
has decided to stop everyone else from
doing this now I can't see the roles
reversing once we get into beyond the
spider verse as Prowler miles will
likely want to travel to the universe
where his dad's alive however this will
have dire consequences and it could lead
to miles's Universe being destroyed
which means that Miles has to take on
the Miguel role this will mean that he
has to stop his pralavarian from getting
out to his universe and it brings a
whole new meaning to the phrase Your Own
Worst Enemy and Miles likely isn't going
to be held there for long as we do see
his finger touching the chain on the
punching bag and then start to spark up
he's of course escaped using his
electricity Powers before and therefore
I don't think that he's going to be held
in place very long that could kick-start
the next film with a big action scene
and another thing I love about this
scene is that he he's tied up to a
punching bag if you go back to into the
spider-verse that's how Peter B Parker
was tied up too and it's just a nice way
to bring these situations together now
we of course also have this spot as well
and I think the time through your time
on this well he may end up befriending
prala Miles because he knows it will Aid
him in destroying miles's Universe on
his Earth we know that Miguel and Ben
Reilly are there too unless we could get
a big action scene between these in the
prolevation of miles and also this spot
so I think the next film will once more
be a Multiverse hopping movie in which
we watch a dark version of Miles
attempting to get across it actually
really like the idea that the ultimate
villain of the trilogy could end up
becoming a dark version of Miles which
shows what he could have been if things
hadn't worked out differently now miles
is gonna need all the help that he can
get and that's going to come in the form
of Gwen cross a Multiverse she was sent
back to Earth after being kicked out by
the other spider people she returns home
to find her dad who has somewhat
forgiven her and the pair have it out
and basically talk about the whole
situation realizing that he'd be unable
to actually arrest her he gave up the
badge which also has a knock-on effect
now Captain Stacy will no longer die in
the line of duty which has altered the
Canon event that would go on to become a
defining moment however the world
doesn't end no black hole is created and
this could potentially show that things
can be diverted we learn that the
original Spider-Man from the first film
was also never meant to die but miles
getting in danger changed that moment
that Universe didn't end either though
and thus there is a potential that
things can be changed I think we might
learn a bit more about what happened
with Miguel and potentially didn't tell
us everything about what triggered the
event although we did see it happen in
Baton so who knows how it's played out
but I'm guessing we're going to learn
more either way I think if we look at it
all then this is Miguel's fault because
his actions and need to control
everything has led to more things going
out of whack as she's left knowing that
she has to rescue miles and there she
goes and pulls in some allies these are
the spider-verse people we met in the
first film along with spider Punk and
Spider-Man India spider bites there as
well I haven't even talked about Peter B
Parker and his daughter that's a whole
nother thing this is how dense that
movie is but it's just one big reunion
of the old spider family and a couple
new additions your boy Nicholas Cage is
back spider ham has returned and Penny
Parker has a much bigger Mech to fight
off again sees upcoming threat now the
way I see things going forward and big
due time for this is that we have miles
being someone who could cause an entire
universe to end up being destroyed
however this won't be the one that we
followed and instead it'll be the
prowler version that we're introduced to
at the end subbing him will be of the
utmost importance but unfortunately
miles will likely have to let his dad
die though he's desperate to keep him
alive Spider-Man's all about sacrifices
and this is something that's integral to
the character if we look back on the
history even without Uncle Ben's death
Peter had to stop himself from being
with Mary Jane at the start of the first
Remy film though she came to him at the
end of Spider-Man 2 he had to go off and
help the police because his Judy was
calling him over her The Amazing
Spider-Man had to give up Gwen at the
end of that first film though we kind of
went back on that and we know how it
turned out and the MCU version had us on
things too no way home had him giving up
his entire life come the end of the
movie and now he promised to tell MJ
about their life he couldn't bring
himself to do it seeing the cut on her
forehead in the donut shop made him
rethink things and he had to leave both
her and it behind in order to keep them
safe though Jefferson doesn't die in the
comics he did die in the game but this
could also show the two ways that things
may go firstly his death would allow for
the universe to be safe and this is so
that it doesn't come crashing down
however if he saves his dad that's gonna
have massive ramifications that will
destroy reality as he knows it left with
little options miles has to decide
whether the needs of the many outweigh
the needs of the few and it's a big way
to take things that massively raises the
stakes now there is the possibility that
his death can be diverted without
affecting anything but yeah let me know
below exactly what you think all right
so my thoughts on the film bear in mind
we're dealing with me just coming out of
it and there may be some recency bias
that turns me into the Schiller man
saying that though complete Banger I
think right now this sits as being one
of the best comic book movies of all
time yes that's right Shilling right now
but yeah coming out of it I I just can't
imagine how this could have been any
better it's a step up from that first
film in every single respect and it
delivers masterfully or not only a
technical level but also a storytelling
one too it's got heart incredible
actions some of the best animation I've
ever seen and a number of deep cut
Easter eggs that Spider-Man fans will
love in my reviews I often try and bring
up other mediums to talk about how I
feel about films and shows and I
actually think I have the perfect
comparison for this looking at
everything in it I think it's sort of
like a video game sequel in that the
creative team took what they learned
about that first film and improved it in
every area for example I've been playing
through Jedi Survivor recently and when
you compare to the first you can see how
they use the foundation of that then go
build something that was bigger in scope
and scale and far more advanced in
what's come before with across the
spider-verse being a digitally animated
movie I feel that a similar sort of
process has gone on here and though
those things from their first film are
still in place we have a clear evolution
in every single area on paper this feels
like a film I should implode because of
how much is going on in it but somehow
it manages to bring all of its elements
together to tell its overarching
incredible Story You've got hundreds of
different spider people high concept
ideas like the Multiverse fatalism
Destiny but it's all wrapped up in a
kid-friendly package that makes the
stupendous easy to understand Amy
Pascal's also just announced that
they're doing a live action version of
Miles very soon and coming off the back
of this I can't wait to see that play
out comic book films have taken a real
knock the last year with us getting
kooky Killer By the Number releases that
add way to the criticisms that non-fans
have over the genre however I think this
is something that fans can be proud of
as it shows the best that this genre can
be by redefining our expectations and
going above and beyond them again it
could be recency bias but either way I
think I'm gonna have a lot of love for
this film and I actually suspect that on
a second watch it's probably going to be
something I enjoy even more coming right
out of this I think it's going to be a
long time before film tops just how
outstanding this is and though I have
hopes for the flash it's gonna be
difficult to outdo this I know you
shouldn't be putting two films together
like this so you know what I'm not gonna
do it but I'm gonna celebrate the fact
that it feels great to be a comic book
fan right now however I do have some
criticisms and when watching it I did
feel like that first half hour was
pretty slow looking back on it it all
made sense to focus on what they did
they paid off at the end but at the time
watching it I was kind of a bit meh on
the opening I had had the movie hyped up
massively and then you know it it got
off good yeah I'm not saying it was bad
but I was kind of thinking where's this
big thing that I'm supposed to be going
crazy over however once they go to Nueva
York everything gets incredible and it
was so good seeing them knock it out of
the park like that across the spider
verse is an outstanding achievement and
for me it scores a 9.5 out of 10. my
drop in a couple of months you know time
can make of you things differently but
coming right out of this I can't
recommend it any higher if you agree
with us then let us know in the comment
section below if you think I'm chilling
I'd love to hear that too and yeah just
drop a comment to let us know your
thoughts on the film if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below and as a thank you you'll
get access to early videos every week we
also have our merch store over at
xeroedition.com and this sells lots of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and more
we're currently pushing a limited
edition Peacemaker and draxin spy
t-shirt so if you want to head over
there after this and help us out then
the links in the description now if you
want something else to watch we've got a
breakdown on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this uh the way huge thank thank you for
singing through the video I've been Paul
and I'll see you on the next one take
care peace